oh we can breathe easier for a bit hurry  on back Trump's has just regained  consciousness hold on I saw something in  Hell mirror had an ally other than  Janemba with him what are you saying  their goal has been to collect energy  from all the battles we've had so far  that means they're probably gathering up  energy right now  you  while fighting as a guard you somehow  absorbed its power very impressive even  for a truly rare talent we're having a  conversation here where's masters or  hide  person Goku espite you  it's very rude  maybe I should destroy you this last  fight strong  I know that face it's Bardock  you grown strong now show me everything  you've got  I'm going in oh there's another one  listen up all of you I want you out of  here you've got a pretty big mouth are  you  the god of destruction oh I happen to be  enjoyed  I've met